[Music]
i figured it out yeah seven times a
charm
don't be an actor oh god
you don't belong with those la folks
they're a bunch of fascist hippies
what brings you here and i figured no
better place to be discovered in the
supermarket hey did i see you on a
television series you do movies you
don't work in any team industry at all
no man
will know you're fussing with this truck
i'm a son just borrowing it i reckon
it's a few months worth of cleanups on
aisle four to pay off a dui impound
what can i get for you miss i got beef i
can see that
hey
hey
let's not waste either of our time i'm a
catholic why ain't that what confessions
for you can't date someone who isn't
baptized
i thought you was gonna say hispanic
where's the water i'll do it now i know
i'm not what you're used to
and not what you deserve either life's
gonna give you a gut full of reasons to
be angry
[Music]
you only need one to be grateful
[Music]
i think god saw something that you were
saving
but it's up to you to decide what you've
got to offer
it's the place you told me you believed
in me i thought it makes sense being
back here to do this
[Music]
your son is about to make a huge mistake
i'm gonna be a priest
for halloween
huh i'm praying for you bill don't you
dare you're violating my right there's a
man
the
going
around
all been wrong and we've all done some
wrong but he came to forgive us
everybody won't be treated all the same
there's no easy way to deliver this news
you have a progressive muscle disorder
the muscles weaken until he ceases to
function is there anything it doesn't
mess with yeah erectile function
i'm trying to be a priest pal the wise
man will bow down before the throne i
don't know
why
when at his feet they'll cast their
golden crown man don't lose when he gets
knocked down
the money won't get up
a baby
there is concern amongst the diocese
that your infirmity will render you
unable to be a priest listen to the
words long written down what you guys
get one phone call a week in here who
you gonna call huh when no one else
gives a [ __ ] what you got to say god
does when the man comes around he ain't
giving up on you don't you dare go
giving up on yourself hear the trumpets
here
100 million angels where are you going i
gotta get your ass to church on time
who are you here to visit sir father
steven
you and everybody else
we shouldn't pray for an easy life
but the strength to endure a difficult
one
[Music]
well you can't say i never gave you
nothing yeah i skipped over thanking you
went straight to the source
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
you